had a crazy delusional
authoritarian dangerous criminal
president of the united states the
horror and terror
that this deranged president of the
united states
visited upon our country donald trump
his character his authoritarianism
his recklessness his neglect his
homicidal negligence
trumpism in all its derangement terror
and horror thank you sir now show us on
the doll where trump hurt you
[Applause]
oh it's friday night and i'm already
drunk
or as cat likes to call it i've already
started drinking yesterday night
tom sulu is with us hooray i guess
we're lucky to have him considering how
he got here tonight
oh no he has a really bad back hope your
back's better tom
so it's confusing to be a college
student in america and not just because
you pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars to make
you stupid i could do that for free with
a hammer
but i kid it's tough to be in college in
america
land of the free home of the brave and
pizza with cheese stuffed crust
yep if you're in college the biggest
threat are carbs
it's one place where you can cry about
inequality while turning your ass into
your own portable ottoman
and if anyone's mean to you there's a
campus crisis center full of fluffy
pillows and emotional support llamas
now you could consider yourself lucky
but if you do
no one's gonna agree clearly america is
the worst place on earth according to
their professors
who judge the whole country based off
things they learn from their own
professors
it's a tenured daisy chain of hate that
regenerates
every year spitting another elite class
of activist brats who think dying your
hair purple
is a brave political stance so as you
know
protesters in cuba have been seen flying
our american flag over the past couple
of days
it's weird right because it's not the
cuban flag it's our flag and that's like
so uncool and xenophobic
don't the cubans know what they're doing
they're offending our students
our professional athletes our olympic
hammer throwers
i mean maybe cubans see it as a symbol
of freedom but how would they know right
campus reform talked to college students
around the capitol and asked what they
thought when they saw the flag
what is the first thing that comes to
mind when you think of the american flag
i would say represents like the union of
all people
but like there's clearly not a union
amongst all of us there's clearly like
so many
structural inequities honestly kind of
like what's been going on with like the
country with all the riots and stuff
i think like the flag is a symbol of
america and obviously like america has
done
some horrible things and like that's
part of our very complex history
shame honestly i felt like if i had the
american flag and was associated with
the american identity i was associated
with
like a lot of bigotry and like a lot of
racism
and sexism and not stuff that i
like really would like to think about
the american flag symbolizing so
it's a symbol of of hurt um
i'm african-american um my family
uh you know really built this country up
it's
it's controversial wow in 52 seconds
i counted 432 likes
and i could feel my brain draining from
me i feel so dumb right now i
finally understand the appeal of seth
rogen
so the students choose to focus on the
flawed past of a country that now has
universal suffrage
equal protection under the law and of
course the gutfeld show
but yeah the flag it's probably just a
piece of cloth
do you think it represents freedom no i
don't
um i don't think it's as free as people
think it is and
i just think it's a piece of cloth at
the end of the day for me
no i don't see myself represented in it
so i would not say it represents freedom
to me i think it
once did but honestly like recently i'm
not too sure anymore
because with like everything going on i
don't know just
i think like we once were free but with
now like there's like just
new laws and like new things coming
about that
i don't know if that's true anymore yeah
like
totally it's like we live in a prison
state it's like shawshank redemption
with less digging and more student loan
debt
here's a tip if america was oppressive
they wouldn't allow its luckiest
citizens to hate it
but i get it you see cuban protesters
cherishing something you hate
it must be hard to fathom why are they
doing that and why are they disappearing
why do you think they're flying the
american flag in these different nations
hmm
i mean we don't represent a socialist
government so i don't know why they
would they would
waive the flag i'm not really sure
actually do you think they're waving it
because it's a symbol of freedom and
democracy
that could yeah potentially why do you
think these people are
waving the american flags overseas
um that's a good question
so why would a cuban fly an american
flag if it's not their flag perhaps it's
a desire to have the same rights we do
to vote to protest to sponge off mom and
dad
while you get high before noon who knows
but i guess the flag just isn't a
perfect image of equality and
opportunity
maybe they should try to fly a different
flag
when looking at all these protests
seeing all these american flags
do you think there's another flag that
they should be flying instead maybe to
represent more freedom or more democracy
what other country do you think they
should be looking towards
maybe like sweden i don't know some of
the
some european countries i think are
definitely doing equality on a
better are doing better at equality i'd
say if like they're trying to symbolize
equity then like i'd say either france
or switzerland
why does it have to be a national flag
we could be flying
the you know equality flag like i don't
believe it has to be nationalistic i
don't think we should put any country
on a pedestal yeah is what what's the
country where like
there's not even really a prison system
they have like really low crime rate
like
where's that country oh wait there's a
country that doesn't have a prison
system
sign me up i mean i know our liberal run
cities no longer have a prison system
they just toss the thugs back on the
street
but i guess canada is better yeah
candidate they don't even have
electricity
but again how can students make any
sense when our own media and politicians
are blaming america for the world's
problems
cuba is also probably trump's fault
covid has on top of the trump sanctions
creator their economy should we find
ways to do war for the cuban people
and for relaxing some of the trump
restrictions on remittances so
we should ease the policy that might
lead to an end to a dictatorship
how does she even find her way to work
every morning and i ask that knowing
that she works from home
of course aoc also blames the u.s for
the cuban crisis and why
shouldn't she that's her brand when she
accidentally spills a glass of wine
has a cavity or can't find her belt in
the morning she blames u.s policy
she blames america's past and ignores
communism's present she's like the nike
of congress
so we so should we worry when college
students fail to see how our country
inspires
so many people around the world who
aren't as lucky as these students
let's ask the angry white male
hey you're a grand old flag you're a
high flying flag forever in peace
how did he not get murdered
in some i suppose it's easy to poke
funded people who have taken our flag
for granted they're
young dumb and full of terror
that's the real truth it's not stupidity
it's fear
they know what happens if they say
something counter to the approved
anti-american message
you can label censor and cancel them at
their most vulnerable it's the perfect
tool for indoctrination
so asking them about the flag i guess
you could say it's like shooting fish in
a barrel
except here the fish would say it's
preferable than to living in america
let's welcome tonight's guest new
audience
she's got more youtube views and cats
falling off couches
host of the lauren chen show on youtube
florentin
he's thrown more handcuffed men into the
back seat than madonna
author breaking blue sergeant shot
sticks larkin
he's so catholic he brushes his teeth
with holy water
most of the quiz show on fox station tom
salud
angry white man and she's been
resuscitated more times than a red cross
mannequin
fox news contributor cat tip
welcome back to the show lauren great to
be here happy
is it really great to be here i was
joking about canada you do have
electricity
for now we'll see how things go with the
increasing you know encroachment of
socialism but it's good to be in america
you know freedom in the air growth
hormones in the beef i love it growth
hormones in the beef
we have electricity internet plumbing in
oklahoma too so a lot of people don't
know that but we do as well
we don't want i don't think you should
tell people that because then they'll
start moving there
you don't want more people there you
want less people there fewer people
so less or fewer fewer quantifiable
objects you do look like a teacher right
now thank you
i'll take that as like it's the glasses
intelligence yes you know lauren is it
too easy
to uh do these kinds of man on the
street stuff with students
uh or is it just point out how i guess
endemic this
brainwashing is you know i've had people
say that this isn't gonna be changing
anybody's mind well it's certainly not
meant to change the students minds but i
think
the important thing to remember is that
these students are not representative of
everybody
and i actually kind of think it is
important that the rest of america the
rest of the world really
understand how university students are
really not uh you know everything
they're cracked up
at least in terms of understanding you
know socioeconomic or geopolitical
issues
clearly it's like that one girl was she
accidentally libertarian does she want
more freedom or does she want i don't
even understand
i don't think she does either yeah it's
kind of sad when i but
i always feel like maybe we're being too
cruel let me
try to imagine you at their age
good times yes can you remember that
period
i was driving a beer truck and uh
partying a lot but go ahead
yes how would you have answered now you
can you can doctor your your
your past how would you have answered
that would you have been better or worse
would you what would you have said
what would you like to have said uh you
well i think i mentioned it here before
my father was in the military 32 years
my mom was active duty for 20.
i was raised on military bases around
the country uh still to this day having
that flag on my shoulder as a police
officer
is always a big big deal to me yeah um
definitely would have had a better
answer than that
yeah what would you have said um
as far as no the american flag i mean it
does it represents exactly that it's
freedom that's that's why
that's why the people in cuba hop on
rafts to try to get here nobody from the
u.s is hopping on rafts trying to get
into cuba that's why baseball players
that come into the u.s for tournaments
and things like that
they asked to stay here they don't want
to go back yeah opportunity is here
absolutely
you know it's bringing a major league
baseball they have not said anything
about this
aren't pro sports supposed to be
political then there's so many cuban
baseball players and they haven't said
anything right not a word no
tom how are you great
i can tell yeah you look very uh you
look very tom chalu today very white
very angry and very male i can't help
but greg i can't help it
i wish you could well look i haven't
been on a college campus since i was in
college
but you know when i was in college there
was a few people like this there was
that one table
of communists you know you know in the
lunchroom and you knew about them
and they talked about this and they held
anti-fourth of july celebrations and
things like that
now it's the majority of students but i
will have sympathy for them because
they have been brainwashed since
elementary school and people talk about
critical race theory and the
indoctrination that's going
on today right the thing is it's really
been going on for 30 years
my daughter came home from elementary
school and she was supposed to write a
report
on columbus and they had three choices
they said was columbus uh
an evil man was he just greedy
or was he just a run-of-the-mill uh you
know bad guy
it was all bad choices so she wrote a
pro-columbus
report and the teacher said what was
your source for this and she said prager
you
yeah so prageru is for people who don't
know an
online uh thing from dennis prager yes
and it was really an angry white male
yeah that's what i told her i said
deep i told her watch the video and uh
she wrote a great report but the thing
is
this is what they do from a very early
age so you almost can't blame
them they've been you know getting this
stuff we said the pledge of allegiance
and when i was in grammar school
many many years ago i remember that good
times
cat yeah if you have kids would you send
them to college
because it seems to me like it ruins
them no my kids are all going to go to
trade school
i want to have plumber daughters um
yes plumber daughters yeah and then
they're going to have a youtube show
it's
all planned out that's true i would
watch the apology
male plumbing company yep yep don't you
take my idea
yes uh dump dynasty it's been yeah
don't there you go i'm taking that uh
it's been really interesting to see all
the like
you know social justice-y types trying
to make all these different excuses for
why you know they are really protesting
in cuba i mean
kobit uh the united states right
but these protesters are being quite
clear about what it is they're
protesting which is
you know the communist dictatorship that
they're living under and what's so
interesting is that many of these same
social justice people are the same
people who say
if you're you know a person of color
calls you racist and you're white
you have to agree with them or else
you're a double racist because you don't
understand
but yet they're trying to you know
explain actually communism to them the
people who are living under it and
protesting it
it's almost as if it's a little
hypocritical i would say it's a lot
hypocrite
i would agree with you oh you were being
sarcastic weren't you i i was using yeah
yeah you know what it is i still go back
to the fact that people want to be
accepted by their peer groups
and right now to be accepted by your
peer group you have to be anti-patriotic
which means the true rebels in our
society are the ones who are patriotic
it's us right people
[Laughter]
wait way to get an applause line tom i
just want to be accepted by my peers
yes that's true your peers are serial
plumber daughters are going to be very
patriotic hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else